und wieder allen masc es ist wirklich
absoluter wahnsinn wir haben ja schon
über seine kritik an künstlicher
intelligenz kurz berichtet und die
großen gefahren die davon ausgehen wie
er und zum beispiel stephen hawking
befürchten seine idee um künstliche
intelligenz zu kontrollieren gehirn und
computer werden vernetzt und kann so
direkt von menschen gesteuert wie das
gehen soll
warum das thema gerade so hochkocht und
welchen verrückten nebeneffekt diese
technik haben würde jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
was ist das für ein wahnsinn in welcher
bahnbrechende forschung steckt ihnen
musk eigentlich nicht wenn naja bei
künstlicher intelligenz kurz k s sei
offensichtlich auch dabei und zwar ganz
weit vorne
dabei warnt er vor ki zitat künstliche
intelligenz ist ein fundamentales risiko
für die existenz der menschlichen
zivilisation so wie es autounfälle
flugzeugabsturz drogen und schlechtes
essen nie sein werden ich habe zugang zu
modernsten künstlichen intelligenz die
es gibt und ich glaube die leute sollten
besorgt darüber sein was gehört zu den
finanzierern von openid einer
non-profit-organisation die ki erforscht
außerdem hat er das unternehmen die
meint finanziert das mit alpha co eine
software entwickelt hat die in der lage
war den besten golfspieler der welt zu
schlagen
eine extrem komplexe aufgabe inzwischen
hat google die firma gekauft und er ist
in wester von eurer link und da geht es
um die kontrolle von ki die verbindung
von mensch und computer um den computer
zu kontrollieren hier ist man
offensichtlich einen entscheidenden
schritt weitergekommen
es sind 27 millionen dollar wohl in das
unternehmen geflossen und das besondere
musk will nicht darüber reden sehr
untypisch für ihn mit diesem geld kann
das unternehmen jetzt gut ausgestattet
die technologie weiterentwickeln die die
verbindung zwischen dem menschlichen
gehirn und computern ermöglichen soll
ganz konkret es sind implantate wenn
alles was bisher entwickelt wurde steckt
noch in den kinderschuhen noch arbeiten
systeme mit denen das gehirn maschinen
steuern mit sehr einfachen methoden um
zb ein bestimmtes kommando zugeben muss
man sich zum beispiel vorstellen seines
haus zu fallen oder ähnliches dieser
vorstellung muss dann einen befehl
zugeordnet werden wie zb rechts gehört
implantate sollen diese umweg in zukunft
vermeiden
doch erstmal will musk menschen mit
hörschäden helfen was soll schon 2020
funktionieren und zehn jahre später
soll es dann soweit sein der mensch
steuert computer mit seinem gehirn
allerdings will maske eine vollkommen
neue dimension erreichen er will das
gehirn wirklich mit dem computer
vernetzen
wir hätten dann als menschen wirklich
einblick in das was computer denken
anders als zum beispiel bei google brain
wo die programmierer
die achseln zucken wenn sie zum beispiel
danach gefragt werden warum der youtube
algorithmus etwas genau macht er bot
nämlich inzwischen auf ki und was genau
macht was niemand und genau das ist die
große gefahr der berühmte physiker
stephen hawking sieht künstliche
intelligenz deshalb als bedrohung für
die menschheit zitat da der mensch durch
langsame biologische evolution
beschränkt ist könnte er nicht
konkurrieren und würde verdrängt
werden so hawking in der financial times
mars setzt genau hier an
die evolution der computer wird damit
zur evolution des menschen
wir wären immer genauso schlau wie die
computer- und hätten die kontrolle
über deren künstliche intelligenz und
noch etwas würde damit dann automatisch
möglich werden absolut verrückt
telepathie über den computer könnten
menschen dann mit ihren gedanken
kommunizieren das wäre wirklich absolut
verrückt unsere welt würde sich
verändern wie immer wenn ich euch auch
über dieses thema auf dem laufenden
halten
wenn er kein video zum thema verpassen
wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht den auf die
glocke hier geht es weiter mit
künstliche intelligenz die größte
gefahr für die menschheit da berichten
wir umfassend über die gefahren von ki
ein video das er wirklich gesehen haben
müsst also drauf klicken und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran